welcome to the reason stream I'm Zack
Weiss Miller joined today by Senator
Rand Paul of Kentucky who has a new book
out called deception the great coid
coverup senator Paul thanks for joining
me today great to be with you thanks for
having me a central question in your
book is did the US government fund
research in Wuhan that directly led to
the co 19 pandemic how strong do you
think the evidence for that is at this
point well you know when I first heard
about the debate or the debate began in
Spring of 2020 I assumed that the
scientists were being honest with us
that previously pandemics had started in
animals and been transmitted to humans
the first SARS epidemic was 2002 2003
came from Civic cats they found the cats
they found that the handlers had
antibodies and then a group of
scientists in the spring of 2020 said
this is what happened I really didn't
didn't pay much attention to it but
gradually over about a year's time
particularly reading uh Nicholas Wade's
article on medium and other articles
about this Alina Chan's work and her
book virality as I began looking at this
the evidence I think was very very
strong that it came from a lab first of
all they checked 880,000 animals in uh
in China and found no animals that had
the virus they checked the blood of the
people who handled the animals to see if
they had antibodies to the virus that
didn't occur either they also looked at
the genetic diversity of the original
people that were getting ill if a virus
is coming from animals it usually tries
to take multiple leaps because it's not
very contagious in the beginning and so
you have multiple different genetic
varieties from the get-go this one
seemed to have a single source and a
single genetic variety very homogeneous
most people think that that also adds
strength to the argument that it came
from the lab so the evidence really as I
began to look at it looked as if it
probably came from the lab then we have
found evidence that U Anthony fouchy and
the other scientists weren't being
honest with us that they were saying in
private exactly uh what I was beginning
to conclude and that's that the virus
the evidence looked like the virus was
manipulated and that they were very
concerned because they do gain of
function research in that lab but in
public they were still telling me and
Fouche responded angrily to me that the
NIH never funded gain of function
research in Wuhan it turns out in
private though he was saying the
opposite he was acknowledging that it
happened and that they had indeed funded
it so these things began to add up and
but in particular the conversations that
the scientists were saying one thing
privately and saying another publicly is
what really got me involved intrigued in
this issue and really motivated me to
bring it all together into this book I'd
like to play a clip of one of your
famous exchanges with Anthony fouchy
from July 2021 where you're asking him
to correct the record after he denied
the government ever funded gain a
function research let's roll
that Dr fouchy knowing that it is a
crime to lie to Congress do you wish to
retract your statement of May 11th where
you claimed that the NIH never funded
gain of function research in Wuhan
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement this paper that you were
referring to was judged by qualified
staff up and down the chain as not being
gain of function what was let me finish
you take an animal virus and you
increase it transability to humans
you're saying that's not gain of
function that is correct and and senator
Paul you do not know what you are
talking about quite frankly and I want
to say that officially you do not know
what you are talking
about what are your Reflections on that
knowing what you know
now well it's a great clip in the in the
sense that his response is that his
experts at the NIH have judged this up
and down the chain have judged this not
to be gain of function research well
this is very intriguing so what we have
been requesting for two years is the
discussion if his scientists discussed
and debated and concluded that this was
not gain of function research let us see
the deliberations so one of two things
are POS possible either he's overstating
the case and the deliberations never
took place or the deliberations took
place and aren't quite as clear-cut as
he's making it and so far the NIH has
refused to reveal any of these documents
so these are not classified documents
but still the NIH is more secretive at
this point than the CIA we can't get NIH
documents or HHS documents we get uh
there are several different articles or
descriptions of discussions that we want
we have the name of them they send it to
to us and it'll be 250 pages long all
redacted so it's making it impossible
for us to assess the truth to have
oversight but it's also impossible for
us to fix the problem if they don't let
us examine what happened this time
around yeah you know there was a
redacted email that uh really made me
start to consider the level of deception
that might be at play here it was this
February 2020 email that fouchy sent
you'll see it there on the left side of
the screen the redacted version and the
house committee uh was able to get it
unredacted and if you zoom in on this
highlighted portion of the unredacted
email this was with his kind of inner
circle of scientists talking about this
phone call where they all agreed they
were concerned early on that this was a
lab leak and uh that concern was
heightened by the fact they say that
scientists in Wuhan University are known
to have been working on gain of function
experiments and kind of further research
has found these uh the uh papers like
this one uh this 2017 paper discovery of
a rich pool of bat SARS related Corona
viruses uh this was a collaboration
between the Wuhan lab and Peter Deek Eco
Health Alliance and was funded by an NIH
Grant and the you know the highlights
here just show that uh basically they
created a bunch of artificial viruses by
combining eight different P bat SARS uh
Corona virus uses with the wi one uh
backbone and then those viruses
replicated efficiently in human cells so
I I guess the the question I have there
is it it's clear in your book that you
believe there's likely a level of
deception here if that proves to be true
what sort of consequences should there
be you know it's a crime it's a felony
to lie to Congress it's punishable to up
to five years and prison after we
determined that fouchy did lie to
Congress that indeed he had funded gain
of function research we submitted the
evidence to uh the Attorney General to
Merrick Garland but unfortunately he's
not done anything with it a year later
when more evidence accured we referred
him again for criminal prosecution and
yet nothing has done but the thing is is
that everything that he's saying there
in private in that email he's basically
admitting it was gain a function he
knows that they funded it he knows that
the the virus looks manipulated and yet
at the same time he was saying that this
is essentially February 1st of 2020 four
days later he commissions a an article
to be written in a journal by his
cohorts one of the main ones was
Christian Anderson in private Christian
Anderson is saying this is not a
conspiracy theory this is not a fringe
theory in fact it may be the most likely
theory that the virus came from a lab in
the paper that they publish at Anthony
Fouch beest they say explicit ly that a
lab constructed virus is not a plausible
idea at all not even plausible not
really to them virtually possible they
in fact conclude in the abstract of that
paper that covid is not a laboratory
construct not that it probably isn't it
is not a laboratory construct meanwhile
saying privately they think it's most
likely we have several of these
scientists saying I'm 8020 80% lab 20%
nature you know 5050 some of them are
saying meanwhile in public there acting
with shity they're acting with complete
confidence but really what they're doing
is issuing a a nothing to see here
notice it's a it's a cover your ass
basically they don't want people to draw
the linkage because they know they're
responsible for funding This research
and that ultimately culpability for the
pandemic will attach to them so it is a
huge coverup not just Anthony fouchy but
throughout government eight different
Departments of government were funding
this type of research and that's just
the non-classified we think there's
still more to be found one of the
research papers that was leaked by a
whistleblower is from 2018 where Dr shei
from Wuhan Dr Barrett from UNCC and Dr
Peter daac for Eco Health were asking
for money and they wanted to take a
Corona virus and insert a special
cleavage site into it that makes it more
infectious in humans it's called a furin
cleavage site well that one didn't get
funded but that's exactly what covid is
is a Corona virus with a a human
cleavage site in it that's never been
before seen in nature and yet when they
saw covid you'd think if you were one of
the people on that Grant you would have
immediately called Anthony fouchy and
said holy cow this new virus has the
same sequence as the same Grant they
were looking for in 2018 that we were
going to help him with beware this is
more evidence and yet nobody told uh the
public list if they told Anthony fouchy
he suppressed it and we only found out
about it not from records releases but
from a whistle blower who actually came
forward and gave us this information
this is the real problem there's this
enormous coverup within government and
we still have to have the information
come out because Democrats still need to
be convinced that there is a problem
that we need to do something about gain
of function research to try to prevent
this kind of accident from happening
again that whistleblower uh is US Marine
major Joseph Murphy and you right at
length about his report uh he is talking
about this diffused Pro proposal uh to
insert the fur and cleavage site which
as you mentioned was not ultimately
funded but that doesn't mean that the
research never happened um and uh what
he says in his in his uh report is
that what they the first of all the
documents were actually hidden uh from
the relevant folder until someone
replaced them after you grilled fouchy
in 2021 and he
summarizes their proposal is basically
an effort to inoculate bats by
circulating an Airborne Universal Corona
virus vaccine in their caves um and even
though DARPA violated it or I mean
rejected it for violating gain of
function um he hypothesizes that that
work might have continued in the Wuhan
lab and that SARS Cub 2 might have been
a precursor to That vaccine that escaped
the lab how much how much the best
theory is is that the chinesee created a
virus covid in order to try to create a
vaccine to oppose it to try to see if
they could create a vaccine that would
work for all Corona viruses the person
who was uh working on these vaccines we
know his name a general zo yusen and
he's developing this vaccine sometime in
2019 but he has to have somebody develop
a mutant Corona virus that actually
infects humans well we think that's what
Co was was developed in the lab to
create the vaccine we also know that zo
got a vaccine and he has it created by
February of 2020 and most people think
there's no way he could have gotten it
that quickly unless he'd been working on
it for some time we also know that this
General dies mysteriously two months
later so there's a lot to be said here
that what was going on is a creation of
a virus creating a gain of function
Corona virus that would infect humans
easily and then uh creating a vaccine
from that and what happened is that uh
it accidentally got out of the lab
we also actually know the names of the
three scientists who got sick in
November of 2019 there we actually know
the name some people say these are the
patient zero and they got sick in N 2019
November and yet the Chinese didn't
admit to anything going on till January
and even in January second week of
January the Chinese are still saying oh
nothing to see here we don't think it's
transmittable between humans meanwhile
it's been cooking and growing for three
months and they knew that wasn't true
how should science funding in this
country change given the facts we've
learned through this discovery you know
this debate's been going on a long time
some scientist uh engineered Aven flu
and made it transmittable through the
air among mammals and people were very
concerned because Aven flu is very
deadly in humans but fortunately doesn't
infect humans very easily so they had a
big debate and they they shut down gain
of function research between 2014 and
2016 the only problem was Anthony fouchy
kept giving exemptions to all the people
that were doing this research and then
in 2017 the pause uh on gain of function
funding expires and they set up a new
committee a pandemic pathogen committee
that's supposed to review things for
safety well all those things sound good
but then none of the Wuhan research ever
went before the committee in fact the
committee the chair of the committee
told me they only looked at three
projects out of probably possibly
hundreds of these gain of function um
grants that they were looking at so what
you end up having to have is I think you
probably need a committee of scientists
uh as well as people in the National
Security theater who are aware of what
kind of weapons can be made from these
viruses you need them looking at it and
trying to decide whether the taxpayers
should fund this I think rather than a
blanket ban of just saying no gain of
function the problem is if you say no
gain of function Anthony fouchy already
says all of these experiments which were
obviously gain of function were not so
he just defines himself out of the rules
and I think they'll continue to do that
but I think you need a committee and the
other thing about the committee is it
has to be independent they have to be
able to review Any Grant throughout
government and they also can't be the
same people getting the money so for
example this Christian Anderson who does
fouchy bidding to write a paper saying
nothing to see here he got a $9 million
Grant the next month so you can't have
the people involved with determining
whether something's safe also be getting
grants from the people that are uh that
are judging the safety of you can't that
that's too incestuous to be a real
oversight condition but we think it can
be done Our Hope still is that we can
get a bipartisan bill out of this we
continue to try to work with Democrats
every day to get them interested in the
issue the hardest part is just the lack
of curiosity the Democrats haven't
really cared much about this a million
Americans died and Democrats seem to be
Blas about doing anything about it you
also suggest in the book some sorts of
controls over the actual materials that
are used in labs to manipulate viruses
or bacterias or you know other uh life
forms and you know we're we're in the
synthetic biology age now and in some
sense like the the the gatekeeping is
gone and it I I just wonder like um how
do you think about the tradeoffs there
in terms of not stifling scientific
progress while at the same time making
sure we don't have Rogue groups creating
superv viruses that cause a global
pandemic you know most research goes
through universities and through uh
Grant agencies giving to the
universities and so I think that can be
policed through a some sort of Safety
Committee application of judging what is
safe and what is not safe but we live in
an era you're right an era era of
synthetic biology you can order on the
internet the RNA uh to create the polio
virus you can literally get on the
internet right now and order the bits of
it if you know how to put it together
you can create the polio virus from
nothing it's almost as if you're
creating life now a virus may not really
be life because it has to live in a
living cell but essentially you're
creating something that you can put into
and basically bring alive from nothing
so I think there should be some rules on
ordering this you know we don't let you
buy centrifuges online we don't let you
enrich uranium in your basement um this
is a I think equivalent to to nuclear
weapons and how many people can die from
this and so even being a libertarian and
not believing in many government rules
this is one of the exceptions that I
think government could participate in
the other thing is is since government
funds so much of this even as a
Libertarian there's no real restriction
on how much you want to regulate
government or regulate the expenditure
of government funds so I think there
needs to be a great deal more done to
this and probably 95 to 99% of it will
be government funds that need to be uh
regulated more strictly Last Thing
Before I Let You Go you know what one of
the major frustrations throughout this
entire ordeal is the way that speech was
suppressed during the pandemic I know
you experienced it yourself you were
kicked off YouTube for uh your uh
comments about masks and we now know
thanks to the Twitter files the FBI paid
about $3.4 million to Twitter between
October 2019 February 2021 for its
efforts to comply with their information
requests and you recently asked uh FBI
director Christopher Ray about that
director Ray did the FBA FBI pay
Twitter money to moderate uh content
moderation I'm not aware of us paying
money to moderate content there or
anywhere else what was the $3 million
for that the FBI gave that's been
revealed in Twitter files then when it
comes to payments uh going back well
over four decades when we are required
by federal law when a company like in
this instance a provider uh goes through
expenses to produce information uh we're
required to reimburse them for those
expenses and so I think that a lot of
the questions about payments revolve
around exactly that and you will repeat
under oath that there was never any
discussion of the
FBI uh to take down constitutionally
protected speech to my
knowledge our agents conducted
themselves in compliance with the law
throughout he said that they simply are
compensating Twitter for taking actions
to address criminal activity um not to
engage in censorship do you believe him
well he may be telling the truth I think
it's an open question but there's the
FBI but there's also the Department of
Homeland Security we do know that they
were working with Stanford University on
internet uh oversight of all kinds of
things not just whether elections are
being influenced by Russians but whether
or not what people were saying about
vaccines we do know from the Twitter
files that they have acknowledged and
also from the Missouri versus Biden
depositions that they have acknowledged
that even things they felt to be true
but harmful to the government position
deserve to be censored the important
part of this debate though is that we
not get carried away many people on the
right are carried away with how terrible
big Tech is and they now want to
regulate big Tech or Force big Tech to
take their opinions I don't believe in
that at all where I've taken uh um
decided to place my emphasis is on the
government half of this equation
if government is V meeting with Twitter
and paying Twitter to encourage them to
take down constitutionally protected
speech we should limit government from
that interaction government shouldn't be
involved with trying to limit
constitutionally protected speech
however if Twitter wants to censor me if
YouTube wants to take my speech down
because I say Mass don't work that is
their prerogative they're a private
company and I would never want to stop
them but it's important we make this
distinction because there are many on
the rightwing populace part of
particular the Republican Party who
saying let's just tell Twitter they they
have to take conservative viewpoints or
let's mandate what is actually let's
have a Review Committee I don't want
that at all but I do think that uh a
consistent libertarian position is
telling the FBI Department of Homeland
Security CDC Biden spokesman Biden White
House that they can't be meeting on a
weekly basis with either overt or
implied threats of you need to do this
or else we know from the Missouri versus
Biden case that they're actually were
threats of anti-rust action being
brought against big Tech or getting rid
of their liability protection if they
didn't tow the line that to me is a
clear infringement of the First
Amendment and uh I think is going to
ultimately be uh the decision will
ultimately agree with that will be the
Supreme Court hopefully in the near
future the book is deception Senator ran
Paul thank you